hace 34 años que ali traoré espera el
juicio por el asesinato de su compañero
y ex presidente de burkina faso thomas
sankara es el único sobreviviente de la
masacre del 15 de octubre de
1987 un golpe de estado en el que murió
el revolucionario antiimperialista tú
tomas todo lo que thomas sankara hizo
durante la revolución lleva el sello del
amor hacia su país del amor hacia su
pueblo
y en nombre de ese pueblo hizo todos los
sacrificios incluso el de su vida
a pesar de haber sido presidente sólo
cuatro años thomas sankara se convirtió
en una figura legendaria del continente
africano pero la investigación por su
asesinato se desbloqueó únicamente
cuando cayó su sucesor les culpa og en
2014 el ex presidente es el principal
acusado en este juicio pero no asistirá
a la audiencia en uagadugú la capital
los admiradores de thomas sankara piden
respuestas
y nuestras expectativas son simplemente
que se cumpla la ley que se diga la
verdad que se arroje luz sobre este caso
sangriento muy sangrientos nuestras
expectativas son que la ley sea igual
para todos que no haya ningún super
ciudadano por encima de los demás
si bien el asesinato de thomas sankara
es objeto de muchas especulaciones sobre
la posible implicación de países
extranjeros esta audiencia se centrará
en los actores burkineses más de 200
periodistas del mundo entero van a
seguir este juicio histórico
para saber quién mató al che guevara de
áfrica